ya hablamos de como la estructura del
adn de doble hélice de escalera torcida
le permite ser la molécula base de la
herencia pero lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es brindar una mejor
apreciación de por qué es adecuada y
explicar el mecanismo que la hace la
molécula base de la herencia nos vamos a
enfocar en un nivel conceptual ojo no
voy a entrar en los detalles bioquímicos
el objetivo es darte una idea conceptual
de lo que sucede entonces esto de aquí
podría ser un fragmento de adn tengo
estos 12 3 6 8 8 pares de bases
dibujadas y sólo para aclarar hablé de
esto en el vídeo de adn el adn es más
que un puñado de pares de bases la
molécula del adn puede ser miles de
millones de pares de bases por ejemplo
este de aquí puede ser a mi molécula del
adn puede ser de miles de millones de
pares de bases o inclusive esta puede
ser una sección del adn mucho más grande
e incluso me dibujo puede que no le esté
haciendo justicia pero bueno esto
aquí puede ser la ampliación de una
pequeña muy pequeña sección de la hebra
imagínate en esta pequeña sección y esta
es la ampliación de esa hebra así que lo
voy a poner así para que veas que es una
ampliación y de nuevo puede ser que esta
es una pequeña sección de una molécula
que ojo no tiene ocho pares de bases
sino tiene 70 millones de pares de bases
o más entonces veamos qué
características necesita tener una
molécula de la herencia y bueno lo
primero que necesita va a ser a ser
replicable ser capaz de replicarse
cuando una célula se divide a las dos
nuevas células les gustaría tener el
mismo material genético no entonces cómo
se duplica el adn bueno a este proceso
se le conoce con el nombre de
replicación déjame ponerlo aquí
lic
vamos a ver la replicación del adn y
agua si hablamos en el vídeo
introductorio recuerdas pero lo que
quiero ver aquí son los diferentes
procesos al mismo tiempo así que vamos a
hablar de la replicación y bueno para
eso lo que voy a hacer es agarrar la
mitad de esta escalera y con ella
tenemos que ser capaces de construir la
otra mitad de la escalera así que de
hecho déjame hacer lo voy a atrapar la
primera mitad déjame ponerlo así voy a
atrapar la primera mitad déjame copiarla
y voy a pegarlo por acá así que ya tengo
esta otra mitad que es nuestra primera
mitad nuestro lado izquierdo deja
mantenerla justo por aquí ok y ahora voy
a hacer lo mismo con el lado derecho voy
a tomar el lado derecho de esta molécula
ok vamos a copiarla apegar la y bueno
ahora que lo tengo aquí lo voy a poner
más o menos por lo voy a poner más o
menos por acá
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es replicar
este adn y cómo lo vamos a hacer bueno
si tengo el lado izquierdo o el lado
derecho de esta escalera con esta misma
información voy a ser capaz de lograr
obtener la otra información y con ello
vamos a tener dos hebras idénticas de
adn y esto es a partir de la información
que ya tenemos aquí porque recuerda que
la am siempre se une con la te recuerdas
la adenina siempre se une con la timina
así que aquí voy a poner te hace una
corte aquí también voy a poner te hace
una corte y aquí también voy a poner una
de la a siempre se une con la tf y bueno
la timina siempre se une con la adenina
así que aquí voy a poner una de hacerlo
un poco más claro
déjenme poner aquí una am perfecto
bueno aquí voy a poner también otra
látex una cola y la guanina siempre se
une con la citosina así que aquí voy a
poner una c y aquí voy a poner una sed y
la citosina siempre se une con la
guanina por lo tanto voy a poner aquí
una g ahora date cuenta que con sólo el
lado izquierdo
obtener también el lado derecho así que
déjenme poner ahora con color amarillo
el nuevo esqueleto de esta nueva hebra
de adn que es la unión de azúcar y
fosfato recuerdas la unión de azúcar y
fosfato y también voy a hacer lo mismo
con el otro lado con el lado derecho
recuerda que sabemos que la timina
siempre se une con la adenina así que
déjame ponerlo de una vez la timina
según la cual la adenina esto va a
quedar así la terminación es siempre con
la adenina con la adenina la del inah
con la timina así que lo voy a poner así
la de nina con la timina la de nina con
la timina la citosina con la guanina así
que aquí voy a poner una g g con cm
con cm y por lo tanto aquí me falta una
c la c se une con la g por lo tanto
puedes tomar cualquier lado de la
escalera y reconstruir el otro lado la
otra mitad y lo que esencialmente
acabamos de hacer es replicar el adn y
todo esto fue un ejemplo conceptual de
cómo se realiza la replicación
antes de que las células se dividan y se
duplique entonces esto fue la
replicación la replicación y ahora vamos
a hablar de la expresión porque
seguramente estás pensando ok esto de
que se pueda replicar está muy bien pero
sería algo sin utilidad si la
información no se puede usar para
definir al organismo para expresar lo
que está pasando
así que pensemos en los genes en el adn
y cómo se expresan han dejado tenerlo
aquí vamos a hablar de la expresión
expresa
acción y estos conceptos pueden tener
varios significados por eso voy a tratar
de explicar un poco al detalle qué son
cada uno de estos conceptos así que
vamos a hablar un poco de qué es un
cromosoma que es el adn y qué es un gen
y cómo están claramente relacionados
vale la pena saber que es que cuando
hablamos de adn
estamos hablando literalmente de esta
molécula de aquí de esta doble hélice
que está formada por azúcar fosfato y
base y tiene la secuencia de pares de
bases recuerdas tiene una estructura de
doble hélice y toda esta hebra podría
ser una molécula de adn
ahora cuando tienes una molécula de adn
empaquetada con otras moléculas y
proteínas formando una estructura más
grande entonces tenemos un cromosoma ojo
y cuando hablamos de un gen hablamos de
una sección de la dl que se utiliza para
expresar cierta característica o de
hecho se utiliza para codificar una
cierta proteína por ejemplo puedo tomar
el color naranja
y decir que esta parte esta parte de la
hebra es un gen porque codificar y a
para alguna cierta proteína puede tener
la información de un gen o bueno de
hecho podríamos pensar en a ver tomemos
otro color esta otra sección puede
expresar se puede expresar a otro gen
porque codificar y a para otra proteína
y los genes pueden ser en cualquier
lugar pueden ser de varios de miles de
pares de bases o pueden llegar hasta
millones de pares de bases y como
veremos la manera en que se expresa un
gen es decir la manera en que obtenemos
la información a partir de esta sección
del adn para codificar una proteína es a
través de una molécula relacionada al
adn es decir vamos a hablar del a rn y
déjame escribirlo por aquí él
en rn significa ácido ribonucleico
déjame ponerlo aquí
sí no ribonucleico ring
clay con ribonucleico como seguramente
recuerdas que significa adn es decir
ácido desoxirribonucleico entonces
claramente te vas a dar cuenta de que
tenemos un azúcar en el esqueleto del
adn es una molécula muy parecida a la
del adn pero ahora está oxigenada no es
de extorsivo nucleico es ribonucleico es
más lo voy a hacer más claro a rené a
efe
m proviene la a de ácido de ácido la r
derribo y la n de nucleicos por la misma
razón que teníamos la n en el adn
entonces qué papel juega este a rn en
todo lo que tenemos aquí bueno pues
particularmente el adn se encuentra en
el núcleo pero la mayor parte de su
información debe salir del núcleo para
ser expresada y una de las funciones que
tiene el adn es ser ese mensajero ese
mensajero de una cierta sección del adn
que sale del núcleo para ser traducido a
una proteína y el paso de ir del adn al
aire en el mensajero se les llama
transcripción
así que dejemos ponerlo aquí atrás
escribe
sión y qué sucede en esta transcripción
bueno primero regresamos a ver un poco
sobre cómo se comportaba esta molécula
del adn así que digamos que tenemos esta
sección de aquí y es más déjame de
copiar solamente la mitad
voy a atrapar y copiar la mitad okay
justo como lo hicimos en el proceso de
replicación voy a copiar y pegar justo
aquí ya está la voy a poner aquí en la
parte de transcripción déjame ponerlo
justo aquí pero ahora no queremos
duplicar la molécula del adn recuerda
queremos crear su molécula de rn
mensajero correspondiente al menos para
esa sección o para este gen o parte de
gen de nuestra molécula de adn lo que
quiero hacer es la transcripción y es
una idea bastante similar pero ahora
vamos a construir una hebra de rn
específicamente de rn mensajero porque
es de sacar a la información del núcleo
este proceso es muy similar al de
replicación a excepción de que cuando se
trata de hacer
la ader y la déjame ponerlo así con este
color la adivina en esta ocasión se va a
unir no a la timina sino al ahora sí lo
ahora la adenina se va a unir al brasil
o brasil
al brasil o el a rn tiene un asilo en
lugar de timina pero ojo seguirá
extendiendo que la guanina las citocinas
seguirán siendo pareja así que cómo
quedaría esto bueno esta se va a unir a
un ahora si lo está se va a unir a un
ahora si lo está aún por asilo y después
esta tímida bueno ésta termina se va a
unir también a una débil a esta tímida a
una den y la estaban y la aún así tocina
aún no citosina esta agua ni la aún así
tocina y éstas y tocina a una guanina y
ya está pero ojo estas moléculas que
tenemos aquí se pueden separar y así
tener sólo una hebra de rn una hebra de
la parte derecha de esto que estoy
poniendo justo aquí que en este caso
sería a rn mensajero es decir tiene toda
la información de esta sección de adn y
después esta molécula puede salir del
núcleo y unirse a un ribosoma y
hablaremos exactamente de como sucede en
futuros vídeos pero bueno este código
también puede ser útil
para codificar proteínas y cómo sucede
esto bueno con un proceso que se llama
traducción déjame ponerlo aquí
traducción y en qué consiste este
proceso de traducción bueno consiste en
tomar una secuencia de los pares de las
bases y convertirla en más secuencia de
aminoácidos y las proteínas están hechas
por secuencias de aminoácidos así que lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
fijarnos en nuestro aire en el mensajero
que tenemos aquí oh bueno no es en esta
pequeña sección de aire en el mensajero
que tenemos aquí deja de ponerla por acá
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es pasar esta
misma información pero de manera
horizontal para eso empezamos con una 1
1 1 y c 1 y hace entonces empezamos aquí
con una y después seguía una a una se
después otra u después otra y después
una hay una c así que déjame ponerlo con
su respectivo color aquí voy a tener una
am
al que voy a tener otra am
aquí me falta una c así que voy a
ponerla aquí me falta otras y si
recuerdas al final teníamos una guanina
esta guanina que tengo aquí que la voy a
poner justo por aquí y bueno esta
información puede seguir y seguir y
seguir y también seguir y seguir y
seguir por acá lo único que hice fue
poner esta parte de la rn mensajero pero
ahora de manera horizontal y lo que pasa
es que cada secuencia de tres bases y
cuidado tienes que ser muy cuidadoso en
donde empiezas porque esto de alguna
forma es bastante delicado en un proceso
simplemente robusto pero supongamos que
empezamos aquí cada tres de estas bases
codifica para un aminoácido específico
así que me tomo aquí uno dos tres este
primer conjunto de tres bases juntas se
le conoce con el nombre de cordón
después me tomo otras tres y tengo 123
aquí tengo otro codón otro cordón y
bueno para acabar del día 12 ya que me
hace falta una base los citó otras 3
tendría otro codón otro color y cuántos
posibles cordones tenemos bueno tenemos
una de cuatro bases así que en este
lugar tenemos una de cuatro bases aquí
tenemos una de cuatro bases aquí otra
vez una de cuatro bases y por lo tanto
tenemos tres diferentes lugares lo que
nos daría 4 x 4 x 4 4 x 4 x 4 posibles
cordones y 4 x 4 x 4 de 64 entonces
tenemos 64 64 cordones posibles cordones
simples y bueno esto es bastante bueno
porque tenemos 20 aminoácidos posibles
lo que permite que otros cordones
también se usen para otros propósitos o
bueno también puedes tener más de un
cordón que codifica para el mismo
aminoácido hay 64 cordones posibles y
bueno necesitamos codificar 20
aminoácidos entonces este cordón junto a
un ribosoma y hablaremos de cómo sucede
esto en un segundo puede codificar
digamos para no ser un aminoácido déjame
ponerlo aquí lo voy a tomar aquí a un
aminoácido el cual le voy a poner
aminoácido 1 este va a ser mi aminoácido
1 y de hecho este aminoácido 1 he
llevado hacia acá por otro tipo de arn
son emparejados por otro tipo de arn
nosotros estamos hablando aquí del a rn
mensajeros recuerdas
en mensajero pero hay otro tipo de aire
en el nt
es decir el aire de transferencia que
esencialmente acerca estas dos moléculas
y voy a dibujar aquí a mi aire de
transferencia va por aquí se abre va por
acá se abre y después formaría algo así
algo siguen y bueno estoy intentando
dibujarlo lo mejor posible pero también
recuerda que aquí junto a esta aún
debemos de tener una am junto a esta
debemos de tener una 1 y al lado de esta
sede vamos a tener un agente entonces
este aminoácido se va a pegar bajo este
a rn transferencia que tengo aquí a este
otro extremo al extremo que tiene estas
tres bases y después aquí voy a tener
déjame ponerlo aquí otro a el de
transferencia otro a rn transferencia
que se va a emparejar con la otra parte
de este cordón que corresponde a una
y bueno este aire de transferencia se va
a pegar a otro aminoácido lo voy a poner
aquí este va a ser mi aminoácido 2 y
como te das cuenta aquí vamos
construyendo una secuencia de
aminoácidos uno otro otro otro y
conforme pones estos aminoácidos juntos
estás construyendo una proteína así que
antes de ponerla por aquí por aquí tengo
uno de los aminoácidos después puedo
poner aquí a otro y después puedo poner
otros más no sé una secuencia de
aminoácidos y cuando tenemos una
secuencia de aminoácidos esencialmente
lo que estamos haciendo es construir una
proteína y estas proteínas son
fundamentales para operar la vida
obviamente sabes que si tú comes a un
animal este animal contiene grasas
azúcares proteínas pero son las
proteínas las que necesitamos más pues
funcionan como enzimas funcionan de
forma estructural no sé los músculos
están hechos de proteínas y bueno ojo
solo dibuje un pequeño fragmento puedes
tener miles o más de estos aminoácidos
juntos
que su vez forman estructuras tan
complejas como las proteínas y bueno
estas tienen muchas funciones de aquí
nace el trabajo de la vida o la mayor
parte de él y bueno espero que este
vídeo te haya servido para entender un
poco mejor cómo se almacena la
información en los seres vivos